[Música]
ah
[Aplausos]
me levanto comienzo bien el día me tomo
uno más y veo la mesa vacía después sacó
el caballo a comer para luego traerlo al
atardecer escuchando una cumbia me pongo
a clasificar todo lo que en la noche he
podido contar papel por papel yo me
pongo a sacar esperando algún día un
billete encontrar cadena tarde me
preparo el caballo entre varas tiendas
ya pero yo me hallo listos para salir el
carro ya está dado le digo a los pibes
que se suben abrigados saludo a mi
señora que se queda en la casa y le digo
no gaste escucho que la plata está
escasa y arrancamos al centro nos
dirigimos a ver si aunque sea en una
caja de dulce equipo con los perros y
amigos recorriendo la ciudad soy testigo
de estar por verdad de la necesidad de
correr por estas calles buscando el
cartón eso sí es un detalle el papel la
botella hasta el día de hoy juntar para
poder hacer llegar unos besitos sea mi
hogar línea
de la comida en la mesa eso es lo
necesario para salir de la pobreza no me
quejo del trabajo que me han dado 100%
buscaminas y vivo preparado para
pelearla y no quedarme parado porque soy
humilde pero que no es raro no me quejo
del trabajo que me han dado 100% busca
vida y vivo preparado para pegarlas y no
quedarme parado porque soy humilde pero
bien honrado y quiero explicar que yo no
soy de esos que se compran zapatillas de
300 euros y después a los chicos los
dejan tirados mal alimentados eso sí
están salvados yo vivo como puedo y es
cuesta hacer ya no se puede convivir con
esta miseria 10 centavos 15 no dan más
veces me tengo que conformar con algo
con peso como vivo yo con eso en la
semana no se puede pensar en un buen
mañana y yo no culpa al presidente ni al
gobierno pero hoy este país parece un
invierno robos drogas secuestros y
violencia siempre culpan a los que están
en la indigencia soy pobre y la
vergüenza no me pasa
y no llevar nada a la casa y hay dos
gracias a dios que no tengo que robar
porque me ha dado algo en lo que puedo
trabajar pero la calle estructura es en
realidad no ayuda y no perdona esa es la
verdad sinceridad es lo que vine a dejar
una parte de mi vida es lo que viene a
contar trabajar es algo que te ha
mandado el carro y el caballo es lo que
dios me ha entregado no me quejo del
trabajo que me han dado 100% buscavidas
y vivo preparado para pelear latino
quedarme parado porque soy un mente pero
bien honrado no me quejo del trabajo que
me han dado 100% busca vida y vivo
preparado para pelearla y no quedarme
parado porque soy humilde pero bien
honrado quiere saber las palmas de denis
desde arriba
[Música]
sí
esta canción quizá mucho las conocen
quizás otros no se llama busca vida la
escribí hace unos diez años más o menos
no me pregunten cuántos años tengo el
cullen allá por el 2008
me fui a vivir hacía poquito tiempo lo
de miso era lo que estaba embarazada
y estábamos tomando unos mates estaban
por comer y se me ocurrió hacer una
canción o tratar de hacer algún relato
que hable sobre la vida de los
cartoneros la vida diaria de los
trabajadores informales como los llaman
así que salió esta canción
no fue la primera que escribí pero sí
fue la primera que grabe o la
oportunidad grabarla un par de meses
después en el 2009 gracias a uno de los
chicos de los pide don bosco bastante
ahora es también cantante esta charla
doble quizá lo conocen y fue digamos la
primer canción que me dio ese pasito
para cumplir un poquito aunque sea mi
sueño y llegar a hacer esto que para
navegador
lago sujeto humano
hacía dos semanas que había entrado a
trabajar en una casa electrodomésticos
muy conocida cambia
cuando me llegó ese mensaje esa llamada
de la producción diciéndome que había
quedado seleccionado
y ahí estaba de acuerdo que fue una
llamada en realidad debía contar así
mejor yo no viva no está en el programa
obviamente porque ya había tenido
experiencias malas en otros dos casting
anteriores había venido talento
argentino a caballo y había ido me había
ido la noche anterior toda la noche con
el frío tomando chocolatada
y aguantando aguantando el sueño para
que después digan gracias que vamos a
estar llamando es como viste tirar un
currículum no empresa y mañana te
llamamos de dice no te llama nunca más
así que no tenía ningún tipo de
expectativa ni esperanza de nada y un
amigo me dijo bueno yo te anoto y que
pase lo que pase van a hacer lo que
quiera el riesgo es total no me van a
llamar y me llaman así que
bueno y ahí fue la segunda decisión más
importante que tuve en mi vida la
primera fue haber ido a vivir con mi
suegra con todo lo que eso conlleva
pero bueno estuve un par de meses nomás
así que la pasé de no la pasé tan mal
la decisión es dada bueno tengo el
primer trabajo en blanco si bien ya
había trabajado no es que no trabajaba
antes no había trabajado pero no todos
los trabajos eran en negro o eran
changas o eran de por tanto así que este
la primer trabajo en blanco algo
efectivo algo quizás seguro para para mí
para mi familia y del otro lado estaba
esto que me había surgido la posibilidad
de un sueño que no sabía dónde iba a
terminar entonces digo que hago o voy
por lo seguro o me decido por lo que amo
que es la música
en un primer momento ni baile había
posteado yo en las redes sociales yo no
por esto mismo yo tengo algo seguro eso
es lo primero que una empresa grande
vaya me llama y digo no no voy a ir
porque como me va a ir acá ni idea sea
quizás voy y me hacen volver de vuelta a
mi casa pierdo el laburo pierdo todo
entonces yo no no hoy y ahí surgió el
apoyo en familia el apoyo de mi señora
de mi nena de mis padres de mis hermanos
de mis amigos de mis conocidos anda
porque es una oportunidad de andar
porque el tren pasa una sola vez anda
porque andas a ver si te va bien pues yo
le decía mira se llamaban y pero si te
va bien
así que entre idas y vueltas charlas
agarré mi bolsito me subí a un colectivo
y me fui a capital sólo así
sin conocer nada
el paso les cuento que llegué tarde al
casting
porque eran martínez los que conocen por
ahí en zona norte y yo me fui a capital
ya fie los estudios de telefe pero eran
los viejos estudio de telefe así que
llegué tres horas después bueno le
expliqué toda la situación me dejaron
pasar cante delante de los productores y
después de ahí vino bueno lo que la
mayoría por ahí vio la televisión esto
que acaban de ver recién es la final fue
un 15 de julio
perdón 9 de julio de 2015 día de la
patria
después de la final se hizo una fiesta
digamos para coronar todo lo que fue el
programa y en un momento de la fiesta
estábamos tranquilos hay un cansancio
increíble no se imaginan el estrés
estaba allá en las nubes se me acerca
uno de los jurados axel y se lo conoce
se me acerca y me dijo un par de
palabras que hasta hoy en día me resuena
en la cabeza me dijo qué bueno
felicitaciones ahora
ya ya pasó todo el futuro ya pasó el
humo de colores ahora tienes que
relajarte bajar bajar un cambio tómate
una pequeña pausa pequeña pausa un par
de meses o lo que quieras y cuando te
sientas decidido a ir después de ese
tiempo volver a retomar volver a hacer
música porque esto obviamente todos
sabemos que la fama es pasajera no es
como que pasa y anda sabes y vuelve en
algún momento lo más difícil siempre
mantenerse
así que eso como me tocó a mí le puede
pasar a cualquiera porque si bien yo
estaba escuchando la charla de los
chicos por ahí a mí me gustaría me
hubiese encantado tener todos los
estudios haberme graduado haberme
recibido de algo y lamentablemente por
laburo o por alguna otra cuestión no
pude terminar pero me tocó esto es el
tema la música y justo como lo hace con
los chicos por ahí yo no reniego hay
mucha gente que pone se queja no pero yo
tengo 40 años estudio y nunca me tocó
a mí me tocó pero lo más importante es
saber mantenerlo porque a ese que le
toca cuando tiene 40 años experiencia
cuando le toque va a estar súper
preparado
a mí me tocó yo no estaba preparado
porque yo no sé cantar yo nunca estudié
canto nunca estoy bien no sé tocar el
güiro se toca nomás en cumbia así que
imagínense
pero cuando mayonesa oportunidad no
quise desaprovecharla yo fui y me mandé
y fui y encare a todos como un camión y
pasó lo que pasó así que quiero
aprovechar para decirles para invitarlos
a ustedes porque todos tenemos alguna
chispa en el corazón de algo de arte a
alguien le gusta bailar levante la mano
que le gusta bailar o bien le gusta
cantar a alguien o bien le gusta el
deporte
a quien le gusta pintar dibujar o bien a
quien le gusta la ciencia
para esas poquitas
bueno en cualquier rubro que les guste
anímense animes a soñar porque yo
descubrí yo en carne propia descubrí que
nada es imposible así como me tocó a mí
les puede tocar a cualquiera así que si
te gusta cantar metete a la ducha por
ahí si no te gusta que te escuche nadie
mete la ducha cantaba poner música al
taco si te gusta bailar lo mismo saca
todas las cosas que tengan rival acá
vamos a ponerte a saltar poner música
para los vecinos para todos si te gusta
pintar lo mismo saca todo lo que tenga
la mesa del escritorio dibujada dibuja
la pared dibujada a tu mamá a lo que
quieras pero hace lo hace lo porque
sirve y cuando llegue ese momento si vos
estás tan preparado
la vamos a hacer bien si no te va a
tocar como a mí que vas a tener que ir
aprendiendo todo en el proceso así que
eso más que nada ese mensaje les quería
dejar que se animen
que salgan afuera que demuestren lo que
sabe porque cada uno tiene un don
quizás uno tarda en encontrar lo
alimento con un medio tarde alguno le
toca yo conozco chicos de cinco años que
ya tienen un don saben tocar el piano
tremendamente y eso es un don cada uno
tiene un don no sabemos cuál es quizás
algunos no saben quizás alguno no pero
eso es un mensaje para mí y me quiero
despedir con esto en lo más importante
en el momento que lleguen si es que
llega nunca se olviden de dónde salieron
no hablo desde el lugar geográfico sino
hablo de los principios de los valores
porque yo puedo vivir acá en bahía puedo
vivir en la china puedo vivir en dubai
pero siempre me acuerdo de mis raíces de
donde salí desde donde de donde me
inicié y les quiero dejar este pedacito
de canción a capella que se llama
siempre estuvo acá
acá estoy acá me ves soy el mismo de
siempre una y otra vez el tiempo ha
pasado y poco ha cambiado el pibe que
camina con la música a su lado que me ha
enseñado que me ha traído valores y
principios que nunca han caído todos los
días aprendo algo distinto
ese es mi instinto jamás vencido en
realidad nunca me fui estoy mirando para
arriba desde el día en que nací si me
quieren buscar me encontrarán porque
siempre estuve acá ya me caí y me
levanté conozco el camino a la cima ya
pase escuché ruidos miré las luces si no
me encandilaron porque firme yo me puse
incluso acusó algunos intrusos dijeron
que me vieron en estado muy confuso pero
se equivocan al hablar porque ninguno de
ellos conoce la verdad y si me voy yo
volveré el lugar de donde vengo nunca lo
olvidé mis sueños en las estrellas están
pero siempre estuve acá y recuerden un
árbol crece bien cuando se cuidan sus
raíces gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]